we have eight weeks of boot camp ahead
of us not working out at all masking
tape it is no friend to chilled aluminum
velcro color-coded efficient
environmentally friendly who's he
talking to
why's he dressed like a registered sex
offender can we focus for a moment
ladies please we need to talk about next
month's meal plan obviously everyone
hated the ceviche and I read the
suggestion box that's on I'm gonna stop
you right there I see through this weak
Act you may have fooled Colossus with
this nice guy [ __ ] but not me don't be
mean back off NCW no no no no no let her
go let her go it's okay she has a right
to be skeptical look at me I'm an easy
target you know historically mischief
has been my mistress so I understand but
I like to think that you guys have
really rubbed off on me I like to think
that I've rubbed off around you too lot
and for the first time in a long while I
like me I accept your apology I never
apologized I was talking to your heart
see you're not lost cause your thoughts
I'm proud you're everything I knew you
can be thank you classes just trying to
be the world's best x-man sorry
ex person hmm something wrong with the
soap that's fine I just filled it give
it a few more pumps there now excuse me
it's dust bunny season and I'm hunting
wabbits
[Music]